welcome to this lecture on saving for
retirement this lecture is about a
question many of you might be asking
will there be enough an increasing
number of Americans are concerned about
having enough money in retirement
here are some evidence from a survey by
the Employee Benefit Research Institute
in 2013 only 13% of workers were very
confident about having enough money to
live comfortably in retirement and only
38% were somewhat confident way down
from previous years and there's only
slightly greater confidence among people
who are actually retired only 18% are
very confident down from 41% in 2007
perceptions are one thing but other
worries about retirement justified in
fact another study by the same
organization looked at how long
retirement funds would cover the
expenses of the early baby boomers or
people born between 1948 and 1954 the
study found that forty seven point two
percent of these individuals were in
fact at risk of not having sufficient
retirement income and that's just to
meet minimum retirement living
expenditures plus uncovered health and
nursing home costs there are many ways
to achieve a secure retirement but I
would argue that the strongest tool you
can have is an understanding of the
joint roles of saving and investing the
principles of Finance have a lot to tell
us about what can be achieved what are
reasonable goals and how to think about
trading off risk and return so suppose
you are one of the many people who
worried about having enough assets for
retirement
well these tools make you less worried
about retirement finances on the one
hand analyzing retirement saving
strategies with these tools may
initially make you more worried one of
the main points we will see is that you
cannot hope to achieve returns that are
higher than those on say bank accounts
or other risk-free securities without
taking on greater risk and one mistake
many people make is to overlook those
risks in their retirement planning on
the other hand understanding what is
realistically achievable without risk as
well as the distributions of outcomes to
which risky assets give exposure will
give you the power to make more informed
decisions you may have to recall
right your expectations but
understanding the trade-off between risk
and return should allow you to prepare
better for retirement and to decrease
your worries